according to North Las Vegas PD three  men were stabbed just before 2 15 this  afternoon you can take a look behind me  as you can still see it's an active  scene now these men taken to UMC where  they are now being treated the severity  of each man's condition is unclear and  we are still awaiting information on  what led up to the stabbings and who was  involved as for suspect information and  arrest North Las Vegas Police have not  confirmed anything the main entrance to  the skate park is blocked off and police  have asked people to avoid this area at  this time but as of now it's still  pretty busy and like I said an active  scene gonna send it back to you